the gyro can experience I know I do to
kill the guy with a choke in the ring
no killed him in a gym he was banging
this guy's wife oh he really went for
him yeah it was crazy he was banging the
guy's wife he invited the guy to school
and then choked him to death and killed
him and then was driving the guys car
around town that's cold-blooded and they
arrested him yeah he was a interesting
character he was a fake Brazilian
jiu-jitsu blackbelt my friend Eddie
Bravo called him out wait a minute fake
yeah I was fake he's a fake black belt
let's go tell everybody was a black belt
and Eddie rolled with them I remember
him coming back to me he's like that
guy's not a black belt I go but you sure
and he goes dude he don't know anything
like it was too crazy it was like he
barely is like a white belt you can get
killed doing this but I thought maybe he
was doing it because he was it maybe
he's just being nice and wasn't going
hard and he was but then as time goes I
was really this kind of snow what the
[ __ ] he's doing and so then he calls him
up and he was like hey are you up are
you a [ __ ] black belt like tell me
about the I said well you know I'm a
black belt in Japanese jujitsu stop stop
stop stop
are you a [ __ ] black belt and there's
like this big pause he's like bro you're
a [ __ ] liar you're a liar
so Eddie separated himself from the guy
and then years later dude wound up
murdering somebody
don't what yeah yeah would you Jitsu
yeah I murdered the guy would you Jitsu
no son the guy well you know I could
teach you how to put a choke it in five
seconds it wouldn't take long at all
yeah I can teach you how to do it just
wrap your form underneath someone's neck
clamp your hand to your bicep put this
arm behind the head squeeze you could
kill somebody it's not a hard thing to
learn but to actually apply it to
someone who knows what they're doing
mm-hmm you'd have to get you have to be
really good like you can't just no one's
gonna let you choke them but this guy
didn't know anything so I think he snuck
up behind this guy who he killed and
just choked him choke him to death
it's not like it was a murder I think he
brought the guy to his school under
false premises he's in jail now all
right yeah shut up to that guy yeah it
was weird because I got uh I got semi
involved in it in that the guy who wound
up ratting him out to the cops was one
of Eddie students
and I was talking to the guy on the
phone about it I was like what's going
on with that guy and then the cops
called me afterwards and said hey we
were tapping that guy's phone we want to
know what you know whoa whoa I'm on the
[ __ ] set a fear factor I'm in my my
trailer
Jesus yeah gettin puttin my microphone
on mic huh you were a murder case sudden
I'm like hey listen I don't know that
guy I go this one I know he's a fake
black belt I told him the whole thing
and I had heard that he killed somebody
but I wasn't sure if it was true because
the guy's so full of [ __ ] this is how
full of [ __ ] this guy was this guy had a
friend drop him off in the woods because
he said he was going to Akuma take
karate contests like a big karate
competition but it was it was no rules
and it was secretive so he dropped him
off in the woods where was this guy from
I don't know I don't know but he lived
in California for a while okay dropped
it dropped him off in the woods with a
duffel bag yeah he gave him a duffel bag
like you had a duffel bag with him
rather mm-hmm it's like a duffel bag
that's just big enough to fit a trophy
in it Yeah right
think about this Bing so he leaves goes
out into the woods the guy comes back
the next day he's got a trophy no duffel
bag see he brought a [ __ ] trophy with
him and then he came out of the woods
like a I won [ __ ] everybody up and
like so this guy would he thought this
guy would tell everybody yeah that he
beat everybody in this karate tournament
this guy's a hell of an actor he's
really I mean he really commits he was
he was one of those guys that's not
really my crazy radar look cuz he's a
friend of a friend so I was assumed you
know I was [ __ ] 30 years old I didn't
know any better I was dumb and I was
like I assumed thirty thirty yeah don't
you fully cook by then now you think you
are you think you are you haven't met
enough murderers yet [ __ ] you have to
meet enough really legitimate crazy
people to have them in the database we
like oh oh you're [ __ ] you're a
sociopath oh well what's worth it worse
a psycho or sociopath mmm so see about
that someone who doesn't care about
someone a psychopath I think is someone
who violently attacks people but in many
ways they're interchangeable like let's
Google that
what is it never seen a sociopath in a
psychopath
think a sociopath can have no violent
tendencies but I think the idea is that
they have no compassion for other people
right like I have a friend and she
thinks her sister's a sociopath
everybody thinks that everything's a
[ __ ] sociopath these days that's like
a hot rat that's the hot word these days
like calling someone your racist right
and someone a Nazi exactly yeah mmm the
quick thing I pulled up well put it up
yeah you explain exactly what it said
but there's just like a Venn diagram
it's so it's a better explanation by the
way every woman who's you know who's
gonna hear this like he is a sociopath
so there's something in the middle
there's like it could be both so
genetically predisposed psyche about
genetically predisposed like mostly
Psychopaths what's happening with the
screen there buddy okay lacks empathy a
psych a psychopath genetically
predisposed lacks empathy and guilt
convincing behavior look how they spell
behavior that's oh it's gone I even
Kenai tonight but look how that spelled
behavior oh yeah what the aiyyo aiyyo
you are higher job success why it's okay
antisocial personality disorders can
form social relationships and treatable
that's the one in the middle okay so the
most CEO path environmentally influenced
feel empathy and guilt erratic behavior
struggles to find keep chops wait a
minute I thought sociopaths didn't feel
empathy like it's the same hmm path does
care sociopaths would feel no guilt
about hurting a stranger so how is that
thing but it's not that I'm saying the
same thing does it feel they feel
empathy when you look at that chart it
says sociopaths feel empathy whatever
close we kind of get it sure
[Applause]